sie sagen Putin hat Oberwasser das war
ein Zitat aus einem Interview mit der
Welt am 5.12 es geht dabei um den Krieg
in der Ukraine wie meinen Sie das und
woran machen Sie das genau fest das
machen ja eine ganze Reihe von Punkten
fest wenn man sich anschaut wie die
munitionsproduktion inzwischen in
Russland läuft wie die Waffenproduktion
läuft von uns relativ unbemerkt ist es
Russland gelungen die Kriegswirtschaft
richtig in Gang zu bringen über ein
Drittel des russischen Haushalts wird
inzwischen in Waffenproduktion gesteckt
China hilft Ihnen sehr Nordkorea hilft
sehr und bei uns funktioniert das alles
bei weiten nicht in dem Umfang bei uns
funktioniert die munitionsproduktion
nicht die Unterstützung der Ukraine
nicht ausreichend deswegen ist
eigentlich ein Wunder dass die Ukraine
angesichts der Übermacht an Waffen und
Munition die die russische Armee an die
Front bringt noch so in der Lage ist
standzuhalten jetzt gibt es ja heute ein
Treffen von US Präsident Joe Biden und
ukraines Präsident selenski im Weißen
Haus denn wir wissen dass die
Unterstützung momentan die Finanzhilfen
weiter auszuzahlen aus den USA sehr
schwierig ist weil die Republikaner das
im Kongress blockieren was kann zelenski
da trotzdem noch erwarten wie schätzen
Sie das ein ich hoffe dass beiden
wenigstens sozusagen noch ganze Reihe
von munitions und Waffenlieferungen
freigibt nicht man darf eins nicht
vergessen es sind ja nicht nur die
Republikaner sondern auch die Demokraten
nicht wenn man in Washington ist und ich
war erst im Juli in Washington dann
sagen die einem relativ offen also das
ist ein Krieg in Europa kümmert euch mir
ihr Europäer mal darum warum müssen wir
als USA immer alle Probleme auf der Welt
und auch noch in Europa lösen und damit
haben sie ein Punkt und wir als Europäer
kümmern uns viel zu wenig darum gerade
Deutschland als mit Abstand mächtigstes
und wirtschaftlich stärkstes Land tut
noch immer deutlich zu wenig und das
werden wir am Ende alle bitter beruen
wenn es so weitergeht hinzu kommt ja
Herr Hofreiter dass nicht nur die
US-amerikanische Unterstützung derzeit
bröckelt sondern eben auch die
europäische Viktor Orban der ungarische
Regierungschef droht am Donnerstag da
beginnt der EU-Gipfel sowohl die
Gespräche zur EU Beitrittsperspektive
als auch die versprochenen 50 Milliarden
Euro an Hilfe zu blockieren gehen Sie
davon aus dass Viktor Orban tatsächlich
sein Veto einlegt und was würde das
bedeuten ich hoffe er wird sein Veto
nicht einlegen aber ich glaube man muss
mit dem ganz viel härter umgehen man
muss sich darüber Klaren sein dass
Viktor Orban im Grunde ein korrupter
Krimineller ist dem geht's mit seinem
Veto vor allem darum um die EU-Gelder
freizupressen um sie dann wieder stehlen
zu können für sich und seine govenbande
die de facto inzwischen Ungarn regiert
und außerdem ist er auch in unter
gewissen Drucksituationen aus Russland
weil er Hal komplett korrupt ist und ich
glaube dass die Europäer da einfach mit
deutlich größerer Härte gegen Orban
vorgehen müssen wie denn wenn es nicht
die EU-Gelder sind die ja anscheinend
freipressen will also was tun weil wir
brauchen ihn ja nein wir brauchen ihn
nicht unbedingt ich glaube das ist der
erste Irrtum das hat man auch gesehen
bei next generation EU man kann das
ganze dann einfach mit 25 sich machen
und man kann ihn am Ende so unter Druck
setzen dass er nachgibt man muss dem
einfach mal sehr sehr klar und deutlich
sagen was die Stunde geschlagen hat ich
meine wenn sie sich das anschauen
inzwischen sagen die Leute Ungarn ist
keine Demokratie mehr die das
untersuchen und das innerhalb der
Europäischen Union und man sagt es ihm
nicht mit der Deutlichkeit und man lässt
ihn immer wieder durchkommen erst jetzt
sind 10 Milliarden freigegeben worden
von der EU-Kommission angeblich aus
technischen Gründen das ist all ein zu
milder Umgang und ich glaube die EU hat
in aller Härte immer noch nicht
begriffen wie sehr sie von außen und
innen angegriffen wird sie haben gerade
schon angedeutet Deutschland tut zu
wenig ihr Vorwurf lautet in Richtung des
Bundeskanzlers to little to late also zu
wenig und zu spät warum sagen Sie zu
wenig wenn wir daran denken dass
Deutschland nach den USA der größte
finanzielle Unterstützer der Ukraine ist
ja wir sind der zweitgrößte aber es geht
ja nicht sozusagen darum wo wir auf dem
treppfchen stehen sondern langs um
letztendlich dafür zu sorgen dass
Russland diesen Krieg verliert und da
langt es bei weiten nicht wir haben die
Panzer deutlich zu spät geliefert wir
zögern jetzt wieder bei den
tauruslieferungen die
monuktionslieferungen stocken s dass die
Ukraine sich nicht vernünftig
verteidigen kann wir haben wie gesagt
viel mehr geliefert als ich am Anfang zu
hoffen gewagt hab aber am Ende hilft
halt nicht wenn es nicht genug ist und
Russland am Ende zu der Überzeugung
kommt diesen Krieg gewinnen zu können
nicht solange Russland der Überzeugung
ist diesen Krieg zu gewinnen wird es
immer weiter machen und es besteht auch
die Gefahr dass es dann weitere Länder
angreift was hilft denn dann also wenn
wir jetzt nach vorne blicken was ist
ihre konkrete Forderung an den Kanzler
Taurus liefern monuktionsproduktion
ausweiten mehr Panzer liefern den Druck
auf Russland erhöhen den Druck auf Orban
erhöhen das wärden z.B ein paar ganz
konkrete Sachen was man sofort machen
könnten W Taurus zu liefern sagt Anton
Hofreiter von den Grünen der Vorsitzende
des europaausschusses im Bundestag
vielen Dank für das Gespräch und das
Interview danke sehr